let's bring in congressman jim jordan to
react to this good morning to you
congressman good morning good morning so
they're saying biden administration if
you come over we're sending you back the
borders are closed so why are we seeing
hundreds of thousands of illegal
immigrants crossing over because it's a
message you send i mean you know look i
i say all the time when you uh when you
pay people not to work you shouldn't be
surprised when you can't find workers
when you defund the police you shouldn't
be surprised when you get more crime and
when you send a message from the white
house we're going to stop building the
wall we're going to get rid of the
remaining mexico policy you shouldn't be
surprised when people come to the
country so there were 15 000 under the
bridge a week and a half ago we don't
know where those haitian migrants are
they can't tell us and now there are 15
000 more coming i mean this is this is
the mess you have when you send the
wrong messages from the white house and
you implement the wrong policies so here
we go again we actually had a briefing
last week ainsley from uh for the
judiciary committee from the biden
administration and they actually told us
they said we think because we we
basically ask where are they where where
how many are in america where where are
they at in the country how many to send
back they couldn't tell us all the
numbers but they also said we think a
number of them have went back i mean you
wanted to laugh like are you kidding
they make this this thousand mile trek
and they're actually just going to turn
around and go but they actually told us
that so they have no idea how to handle
this again when you send the wrong
messages from the white house bad things
happen well congressman they don't want
to give the number because half the
country would like to see people who
come into the country immediately
deported and the other half of the
country wants to have them all come on
in yeah yeah no they just keep
misleading the american people but again
well i don't i think it's probably more
than fifteen thousand some of the
numbers they told us last week it's 20
30 000 on this caravan this this long
march towards our southern border it's
probably a bigger number than even that
and my guess is the 15 000 that we heard
about over the last couple weeks that's
probably a bigger number as well and
when you think when the focus becomes
one area the area around the del rio
bridge the all kinds of people are
getting in going around that area too so
we don't we don't know about those
individuals who are in the country so
this is a total mess and just nine
months ago
just nine months ago we had a secure
border this kind of chaos all unfolds in
nine months and i've said this probably
every interview in the last month every
month got worse march was the largest
month on record for illegal crossings
until april april was the largest month
until may until june june until july
when 212 000
illegal migrants encounters on our
border um this is this is a complete
disaster but it's it's all to pete of uh
of joe biden in his administration the
final thought is
one thing i think mark morgan and
company we're good at doing is going to
these other countries and saying listen
you got to stop what are your issues uh
we're holding back aid uh until you can
get in control of your borders because
they're coming our border we're friendly
with panama we're friendly with the
columbia they're coming through the
darien pass at a staggering clip of 30
000 in august there used to be a very
small number during the day go up to
panama and colombia and say guys control
it incentivize and do it if anyone's
interested in stopping the the genesis
of the problem they go to where the
people are yeah no i thought it was
interesting last week joe biden speaks
at the united nations and says he's
going to restore our relationship with
our allies as if it wasn't good under
president trump it was just it was great
under president trump and while he's
saying that we have this this situation
that you just described where we don't
have these kind of relationships this
kind of cooperation with our friends in
central uh america we don't have them
which we did have under the trump
administration i thought it was i mean
not to mention the fact that when joe
biden's making that statement we need to
restore our relationship with our allies
at that very moment the democrats in
congress are taking out the iron dome
defense system for our best ally the
state of israel um this is how this is
how bad it is and france recalls their
ambassador that's how bad it is good
luck you gotta try i think that's one of
the things let's talk about the 3.5
trillion dollar reconciliation package
democrats want to raise the borrowing
limit republicans are furious about that
they say that it's going to republicans
say it's going to kill our jobs our
wages our electricity prices are going
to go up it's going to lead to
stagnation and inflation which is the
number one concern now for americans
corporate tax could go up to 28 percent
and raise taxes for the wealthy families
and we're talking about immigration pay
for illegal immigrants to go to
community college yeah no it's a
disaster i mean and and of course you
add to all that when joe biden said it's
not going to cost you i mean these are
the tweeted that yeah yeah trump
colluded with russia the hunter biden
story was disinformation misinformation
and and oh a 3.5 government 3.5 trillion
government spending bill won't cost you
a penny i mean you got to be kidding me
this is what they tell us and then you
described everything that was in it this
thing is terrible for the country let's
hope it doesn't pass i mean this would
be great this would be the first time we
could actually slow him down well that's
actually not not us this is this is a
democrat fight let's hope that they
can't get it done and don't do any more
damage to the country than they already
have well let's talk a little bit about
what happened yesterday the senate
republican said
absolutely not democrats we are not
going to go along with chuck schumer we
are not going to raise the debt ceiling
and we will not simultaneously fund the
government because it's going to run out
of money at midnight on thursday they
did the republicans did say we will do a
clean resolution where we fund the
government and we pay for hurricane
relief but we're not going to go along
with the debt ceiling thing explain for
folks jim why republicans say we cannot
allow the debt ceiling to be raised on
our watch yeah because if you raise the
debt ceiling you're allowing this 3.5
trillion dollar monstrosity with all the
bad policies in it to go forward if they
get the votes for it so we're like
knowing that in the debt ceiling it's
look joe biden's in the white house
chuck schumer controls the senate nancy
pelosi controls the house of
representatives it has nothing to do
with republicans if you want to raise
the debt ceiling and you can you can
actually get the votes to do all the
crazy spending you want to continue to
do that's that's on you guys don't talk
to republicans about that and we will
help them if it's just spending at the
current level we could we could be
helpful on that we're not going to help
them increase spending we're not going
to help them with this debt ceiling
increase makes absolutely no sense and
frankly the american people know that
they know that and that's why the
democrats are trying to blame the
republicans who don't control a darn
thing in this town well one thing is
pretty clear we're all embarrassed as a
country the way we left afghanistan
embarrassed that we left allies and
citizens at home they are still there
embarrassing left 85 billion with her
equipment it is still there and being
resold embarrassed that we asked the
taliban or to watch our backs as we
tried to get out of the airport
austin
mckenzie and millie will be on capitol
hill today and tomorrow yeah tell me
what you need to know
well the first question i'd ask general
miller is your name ever been on a
ballot you ever run for office making
the decisions you're making as reported
by bob woodward in his book if he
actually i mean it's the same question
i'd ask a lot of these people dr fauci
ever run for office jim comey ever run
for office lois lerner ever i mean the
idea that these people who never put
their name on a ballot or making
decisions for the american people that
is not how our system works so the
question i'd ask general miller is when
did you run for office and make these
kind of decisions where you can over
when you can overrule basically the uh
the president of the united states trump
if this effect happened overall
president trump i mean for goodness sake
that is so wrong so so inconsistent with
our constitutional system i hope those
are the kind of questions that he gets
and then then then i would get into 13
service members gave their life for
their country one from the fourth
district of ohio americans left behind
allies left behind 85 billion dollars of
equipment and weapons left behind and
joe biden the commander chief calls that
an extraordinary success are you kidding
me so that's the kind of tone i would
take with with general milley i'm not on
that committee but i'm sure some of my
republican colleagues will do just that
well and and we've heard a number of
people from the pentagon and on capitol
hill go well you know what he was doing
where he called his counterpart that's
normal you know we expect them to do
that i think the average american jim
never realized that
a top general would be calling up his
counterpart in china saying oh you think
your boss is crazy mine's crazier and
i'm not going to let him uh drop the
bomb on you yeah and if he said if he
said to our enemy the chinese his
counterpart in china if he said if we're
coming i'll give you a heads up if he
said that that is that is absolutely
wrong no no tolerance whatsoever for
that kind of statement if he said now we
don't know but i mean the other question
when you'd want to ask general miller is
what in the world are you doing talking
to reporters anyway you're not your name
is not on a ballot you don't run for
office what are you doing talking to the
press your job is to be chairman of the
joint championships
you know why he did it because he wanted
to show bob woodward he was the adult in
the room yep and can we not get those
transcripts to
determine whether or not he did say that
i hope so but i doubt it's going to
happen with democrats in control
lieutenant colonel stuart sheller came
out and spoke he said they need to be
held accountable to our generals and
commanders after the afghanistan
marine for 17 years instead of retiring
in a year he quit and now they're going
to try him and they put him in jail as
he waits trial let me ask you something
general milly presided over our forces
along with secretary of defense austin
we just killed 10 civilians and seven
kids we had 13 uh service men and women
die
guarding an airport that was being
guarded by the taliban
you put this guy in jail waiting trial
where's their trial no i know and the
you can you can feel that individual's
frustration you can feel the american
people's frustration with what they see
and what they hear um i'm i'm
i'm just so tired of the double standard
there's one set of rules for the elite
in this town a different set of rules
for all us regular americans and this
seems to fit into that that broad
category as well i am so sick and tired
of that i think americans are sick and
tired of that um and the press the
mainstream you guys do a great job but
the mainstream press covering for people
in the bureaucracy who abide by a
different set of rules and standards
than all of us americans all of us
taxpayers i mean
it it drives us all crazy uh god bless
this uh this individual god bless those
those families are those 13 i mean max
soviet is an individual from the fourth
district of ohio you know he was just a
great young man serving our country gave
his life for our country and then we see
this kind of stuff happen and it is uh
it is frustrating our commanders are not
worthy of our war fighters that's the
problem and the marine that is jailed
his dad said all our son did has asked
the question that everybody was asking
themselves
but they were too scared to speak out
loud he is thank you congressman thank
you